[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spider-man and it looks
like Sony are building towards a
sinister six movie in the spider-man
Marvel Universe with Amy Pascal dropping
some big hints in a recent interview
throughout this video I'm going to be
going over the interview with the Sony
exec and giving my thoughts on it now
there will be some spoilers here so if
you want Bully up-to-date with far from
home then this is your last chance to
back out make sure you subscribe to the
channel and ring the bell for all the
latest update on spider-man and the MCU
as well as up-to-date coverage of movies
TV shows games and more without the way
I just want to give a huge thank you for
click in this video now let's get into
the breakdown okay so just before the
release of far from home we did have
rumors that were reported by CGI artists
that reportedly worked on the film that
one of the post-credits scenes for the
movie showed Norman Osborn in the newly
converted Oscorp tower meeting with the
members of the sinister six
Osborne had taken over stock Tower and
this is why in teasers and the film the
building appeared to be vacant
apparently this seemed teased the
introduction of the villainous group to
the universe and was a big step forward
for the franchise the scene was supposed
to feature Mysterio Bulger and Scorpion
but evidently if it ever did really
exist then it didn't make it to the
movie now leakers did say that this was
Paul due to the Sony and Disney deal
being collapsed at this point
and neither studio wanted to really
tease anything major without knowing how
things would be working for the
character going forward take all of that
with a grain of salt because as I said
we don't have confirmation on it
however it does indeed look like Sony
are building towards a sinister six
movie with his newly released feature
rant that comes on physical copies of
spider-man part from home I'll drop the
clip in just a second but pay close
attention to what Amy Pascal says and
how she phrases it I'll play this twice
because it whizzes by really quick so in
case you missed the first time it loop
back around now let's get into the clip
that we now have in our universe happen
to be character
that are in the sinister six there may
be something that happens to that no
matter where he goes the world is going
to be different for him here's the real
blockbuster
brace yourselves you might want to sit
out spare man's name is Peter Parker
what no more hiding yeah no more hiding
these villains that we now have in our
universe happen to be characters that
are in the sinister six there may be
something that happens no matter
okay so Pascal pretty much makes it
clear that the studio's have been slowly
introducing the sinister six into their
films and that there are plans to do
something with that this makes sense as
to why scorpion was teased in homecoming
but then never appeared and far from
home and also adds a lot of weight to
the rumor that Drew Goddard is still
working on a sinister six film now this
was initially in development from the
cabin in the woods director and was due
to follow up on the amazing spider-man
series but after that fell through
rumors of the villain team-up date as
well
however we know from this that Amy
Pascal was still really interested in
pursuing this Avenue and I don't think
that she would have dropped it in the
video if she didn't at least have some
big plans for it the post has also been
promoted on Reddit in the Marvel Studios
thread so it seems like the
corporation's could be at least pushing
for awareness of this now we can't see
who promoted this so we don't know how
legitimate it is but someone is
definitely putting money into it what
could happen in spider-man 3 is that now
all of the villains know that spider-man
is Peter Parker they start gunning for
him separately before realizing that
they're stronger together and I
definitely think that this little clip
is laced with the subtext that we may be
seeing them sooner than we think to me
it makes a lot of sense to travel down
this Avenue and the seeds are definitely
there at the moment to assume that
things are going ahead especially due to
Pascal's statement for those who don't
know Pascal is pretty much being the
creative mind behind a lot of the
spider-man Sony projects and she's been
working closely with Marvel Studios CEO
Kevin Feige in order to bring the best
version of spider-man to the MCU if you
look at the MCU films and generally tend
to tease and build up to things so the
pattern so far in the spider-man series
definitely seems to be aligned with that
and I think it makes a lot of sense for
the movies carried out in the franchise
so far personally I really can't wait
for this and I think if we do finally
get a sinister six film it could be the
best villain showdown in Spidey's long
and rich cinematic history now obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on this
and if you're excited for the film
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please like it but
make sure you check out my breakdown of
this week's other big comic book movie
release
Joker which should be linked at the end
I've got loads of videos giving my
theories on the film so definitely check
them out if you want something else to
watch after this you want to come chat
to me on Twitter then make sure you
follow me at definition whitey and if
you want to join my discord that make
sure you click the link in the
description below we've got an awesome
community and it's the best way to stay
up to date with the channel so hopefully
I see over there after this also just
want to let you know that we're
currently giving away a free copy of
spider-man far from home on blu-ray and
all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on the
sinister six announcement in the comment
section below the winner will be chosen
at random on October the 15th and the
bureau be shipped out from then to ever
gets the prize so best of luck that
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for take the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]